providing a good user experience for
consumers of your api
is crucial this work continues even
after
you've intentionally built your api with
simple and intuitive design
it's also equally important to enable
developers with self-service tools to
easily find
and learn how to use your api so they
can ultimately build their app using
your apis quickly and securely
apigee's configurable developer portal
enables app developers with api
discovery exploration learning and
testing and so in this episode
we will learn more about the developer
portal
[Music]
whether the apis you build are for
internal or external use
the developer portal enables api
developers to
publish your catalog of api products
offer detailed documentation for each of
those products
create an easy app developer onboarding
process
have mechanisms to create an app and an
api
key you can even try out your api
you can also leverage the default
templates or customize the portal's
styling to suit your company's branding
and what's nice
is that it's connected to your apigee
console which centralizes
all your api management tasks in one
place
including api analytics which we will
dive in another episode
now let's take a quick tour from both a
publisher's view at setting up the
portal as well as the consumer's view
accessing the portal in prior episodes
we talked about how to create a cloud
project
enable apigee apis create an evaluation
org
then log into apigee.google.com build
your api proxy
and later bundle one or more proxies
into an api
product now to create a portal from this
same console
visit publish portals the plus portal
button
to create a new portal since i already
have one i will click cancel and use
this one
next you will see the different items
you can configure in your portal
now we added an existing api product by
selecting api catalog
the plus sign in the top corner and then
select an api product
then select next to go to the api
details page you also need to check the
box called published
to be able to be listed in the catalog
next you
need to associate the documentation for
that api product
the format of the documentation is an
open api specification
which is an industry standard in this
demo i already created one for this
simple proxy
you can then add an image and associate
categories
that help make the api searchable on the
portal
then click save once you have added the
product
and published the documentation you can
actually visit the developer portal
to see what it looks like by selecting
the live portal link to launch it this
is a developer portal
that apigee provides to get you started
and to make changes to the pages and
theme
you can return to your portal's
configuration options and then choose a
page for example
get started this will open the page
editor
where you can make changes using
markdown's simple formatting
which is then converted to html to
render the page
in your browser now let's see the view
from an external app developer visiting
the portal
app developers first sign up to create
an account and log in
so they can create an app and get an api
key
after that this is the landing page for
a consumer app developer
they can see all the api products
available and explore their details
i can view those endpoints to understand
how they work and i can actually
execute a call to try it out if i don't
have an api key
i get an error to create my own api key
i visit new app enter app details
and enable the api product i wish to use
and click create now apigee registered
my app
and assigned a key to it which i can
quickly copy
now let's go back into the api product
and test out the key
click authorize and from the drop down
you can see that it knows i already
created an app which i select and click
authorize now i can make a call which
you can see
it points to my demo app inside of my
evaluation org and is using
this product great so to wrap up let's
do a small recap
apogee provides a configurable app
developer portal
out of the box which is publicly
available on the internet
where developers can find your api
catalog sign up
register their app to get an api key to
use with the apis
the interactive api documentation allows
developers to test out the api while
they're also developing their app
if you found this episode helpful
community you can subscribe to learn
about
more episodes on getting started with
apogee's api management toolset
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
you